[Musique]
avec le département qui avait justement
envie de communiquer autour des centres
de santé sexuelle pour montrer
l'importance qu'ils avaient sur le
territoire et donc nous pour faire
connaître ces centres de santé sexuelles
on a eu l'idée de d'organiser une table
ronde avec Sandrine Arcizet qui est
aussi chroniqueuse et marraine de la
team 78 Edwige justement qui a un compte
Instagram avec plus de 200 000 abonnés
et deux références santé et ça
permettait en fait d'aller chercher une
audience assez large puisqu'elles ont
des communautés très grandes et
d'informer le plus grand nombre sur ce
que fait le département pour les centres
de santé sexuelle et ce que fait les
centres surtout pour les Yvelinois
[Musique]
ça va être d'informer aussi et d'éduquer
sur la vie affective la vie sexuelle on
va retrouver des sages-femmes des
médecins pour pouvoir aussi avoir des
consultations qui sont totalement prises
en charge et ça permet aux jeunes
d'avoir des personnes à qui parler à qui
communiquait parce que des fois c'est
peut-être pas forcément au sein de sa
famille on a peut-être pas les bons
interlocuteurs donc ça permet aussi de
décloisonner un peu les discours autour
de la sexualité et d'être un peu dans
une safe place où on se sent en sécurité
et à l'écoute
[Musique]
ça permet de les casser surtout ça
permet de je pense décomplexer aussi au
sujet de la sexualité parce que c'est
pas forcément quelque chose dont on
parle mais en revanche voilà d'avoir des
références qui en parlent d'avoir des
influenceurs aussi qui prennent la
parole sur ces sujets c'est important ce
que ça permet de se dire ben en fait moi
qui pensais que c'était un tabou
finalement ça en est pas on se pose tous
les mêmes questions et au final ça
permet aussi je pense de de casser les
codes et d'ouvrir aussi les questions
sur ce sujet là
[Musique]